first of all let me express my gratitude
to the course directors for allowing me
to do this yet a second year so I'm
amazed actually after the first time I
thought this was a marvelous class to be
able to take as an undergraduate it's it
really has been a interesting trip I've
seen some of your exam questions and I
don't envy you I thought to myself my
god I couldn't answer these myself but
by listening to this week in virology I
could actually discern the answers what
that's right how many are there that's a
very good question I'm sure everyone in
this room knows how many genomes there
are and how the reproduction cycle
begins it's something that I actually I
knew that at one time you know way back
in my undergraduate education but of
course I drifted off into another field
called parasitism which well viruses are
parasites there's no question about it
but they're so small that you can't see
them I prefer parasites that you can see
with your naked eye so I worked my whole
life on a parasite called Trichinella
spiralis which some of you might know as
trichinosis which if you look at it in
the proper setting it's a very very very
very large virus because it lives inside
of a cell but that's you know another
course I wouldn't do that to this course
I don't want to waste your time here but
just know that anything that affects you
that you can almost not see or that you
could see but it isn't actually taking a
bite out of you like a lion or a
predator those are probably parasites so
you can start at the very bottom of the
scale of life and work right up to
insects some of them there are some
insects or arthropods that actually live
inside so today it's nice to know where
these things come from and where they're
going I can't tell you where this was
going although I can tell you where it's
been so West Nile virus is a flabby
virus so you've heard about flaviviruses
right
so what do you know about them come on
anybody just shot it out what does the
word mean whose Greek anybody here Greek
no nobody belongs to a fraternity or
sorority here all right so that's a good
thing actually so the word flavia is a
Greek word and it actually means yellow
so can you name another virus in that
group yellow fever exactly right and
yellow fever played a huge role in the
history of this country pardon me in the
history of our medical school because
two of its graduates actually sacrificed
their lives trying to find out which
vector or insect transmitted yellow
fever from person to person and all of
that was under the directorship of
Walter Reed who was a very young man at
that point but of course matured into an
older person and in fact if you've been
to Washington DC there's a whole
hospital and a medical complex named
after Walter Reed who became very famous
for his work in the army he essentially
allowed the Panama Canal to be to be
built because once we found out which
insect vector it was we could begin to
hone in on controlling it now it
shouldn't surprise you then to learn
that almost all the flabby viruses in
fact all of the flaviviruses that I can
name are transmitted by vectors or
insects of some sort some are
transmitted by ticks as well and that
wouldn't be an insect that would be a
what an arachnid eight legs rather than
six legs it was the easy way to remember
that so if you want a vector for ticks
that everybody's familiar with Lyme
disease would fall into that category
right so that's something that you can
probably get right now in fact if you go
head walking in the woods you're likely
to pick up tix and the ticks are likely
to have this infection inside of them
because about fifty percent of the tix
of a particular species have Lyme
disease in there capable of transmitting
it is my voice okay tends to trail off
at the end of my sentences so it's okay
so West Nile virus listen I'll where the
heck is is there a West Nile I mean I
named the story that I wrote after this
the West Nile story sort of as a little
plan when it's West Side Story West Nile
story but the way this actually works is
kind of interesting because the West
Nile virus comes from the western
portion of Uganda it's west of the Nile
River and then there are many branches
to the Nile River so the branch of the
river that it's west of is this branch
right over here and here is where it was
first discovered and they of course
colored it in as a yellow area because
it was a flat E virus if you look now
where it's found its head its extended
its range so the real question is how
did that virus ever come here what
brought it here how did we ever get
involved with it and what are the
ramifications of that so that's what I'm
going to spend most of the time talking
about because as Vince must have told
you before I'm not a virologist not by
training not by application I had been
dragged into this subject kicking and
screaming by a wonderful teacher to be
honest with you when I was a graduate
student I went to Notre Dame for my
degree there weren't any parasitologists
there that studied the ones that you can
see they were all virologists except for
me so every Saturday we would sit around
a table in the morning and listen to all
of the graduate students in the other
virology groups give their presentations
and finally naturally I was last if
there was time
but it's okay because three of them
didn't make it through and i did so
that's the way that goes so what we have
here is a distribution map and it might
be hard to see but it was on the Chris
works right so you could see these
things this is an interactive map that
you can actually go to and push these
little red buttons and you can find out
information about the West Nile virus in
that country you'll notice now that
there are little red dots all the way
down through South America there's
nothing in Brazil yet but I'm sure that
it's there they just haven't looked for
it much the point is that it never used
to be here ever until nineteen ninety
nine that's pretty bizarre right here's
an epicenter for a disease that we can
actually say started we can almost give
you the exact day that it started
they're very few other things you can do
that for in terms of infections another
one that I won't even tell you about
though is cholera believe it or not we
know exactly when that one started to
back in the 1800s so the transmission
cycle for West Nile virus is pretty
straightforward you have to be an
infected animal first and along comes a
mosquito and the mosquitoes how many
people here have ever been bitten by a
mosquito be honest I should have said
how many people have never been bitten
by a mosquito I want to sit next to you
oh you want me to sit next to you I
don't know I always gets the mosquitoes
mosquitoes are attracted to me and my
wife loves sitting next to me for that
reason because they're less attracted to
her then you understand why mosquitoes
seek out people you tend to emit co2 in
your breathe out in fact you always do
that so the co2 comes out of your mouth
and sinks to the floor because it's
heavier than air and if you're sitting
on your lawn chair and it's the evening
and you're sipping your mint julep
watching the sunset having a grand old
time in your backyard but gets to be
around nine-thirty at ten o'clock go
inside and finish the drink there
close your windows put up some screens
and you'll be fine welcome to storm door
repair and this is a change classes is
not the virology thing oh yeah have to
give the cred something to laugh at you
know we were glad you came to trust me
on this so this is the mosquito here and
try to guess how many different kinds of
mosquitoes there are in the world it's a
hard thing to guess at but I can give
you the answer it's about 1,500
different species of mosquitoes and not
all of them prefer humans when I say
prefer it means a lot of them even
though they don't prefer humans will
feed on humans no matter what if they're
desperate for egg production and you all
know that it's the female mosquito that
does the biting right when they all sort
of like we made it and she went off I
don't know where she is but they both
feed on something else they both feed on
plant uses they actually suck out the
sugary portion of a plant and that's
what they use for their own food so in
order to produce eggs you need a lot
more protein than just a sugary solution
so that's why the female mosquitoes bite
because they suck your blood they then
plasmapheresis anybody here familiar
with plasmapheresis you take you're
nodding your head what is it yes this is
a good so so that means in order to
explain a lot they can just talk to each
other and fight at the whole thing right
so plasmapheresis is right you take that
the formed elements out of the blood and
you pack them down and those are packed
Nicole packed red cells but you can also
see this little Buffy coat on the top of
the pack red cells those are the white
cells then a lot of this stuff above
that that's the that's the plasma so
this mosquito species all of the females
they pack the blood cells into their
diverticula in their in their abdomen
and they throw away the serum park you
don't want they just store the red cells
then they digest them and then they use
that protein to make eggs so that's why
they bite us they live we're about two
weeks
they're all aquatic insects every one of
them has to breed in the air basically
and then lay their eggs on water each of
those 1500 species of mosquitoes is like
watching each of us go to a wendy's
salad bar uh-huh where did that come
from right well that's okay because if
this whole class including the two
professors in the back and myself lined
up with a big plate and the salad bar at
wendy's because i think it's got lots of
variety at least and we all finished you
sure you're done yeah all done sit down
and you separate everything back out
again no two of us would have the same
amount of anything on our plates it's
true just watch that sometimes nice
sociological study that's the way
mosquitoes feed each one of us could be
a different species of mosquito and each
one of these little items could be
animals in their environment and so each
one of these has an individual managers
you have to pay attention to it just not
a mosquito it's on mosquito so which one
was the one that carried yellow fever
that cost the lives of two medical
students at pns back at the turn of the
century it turned out to be the yellow
fever mosquitoes they came to name it
was called aeds a gyp time as a very
special breeding site breeds in
temporary bodies of water but that's not
what transmits the West Nile virus it's
a different mosquito and it's one which
is distributed almost all over the world
because we made it happen we actually
distributed this mosquito with our bad
habits we are the sloppiest animal on
the planet when it comes to water we
love to pollute it and there's a
mosquito that was selected for life and
polluted water it's our best friend or
where it's best friend we're not our
best friend and it's it's the Culex
group of mosquitoes okay it's not the
kind of trend that transmit malaria and
it's not even the kind of transmitter
yellow fever this is the kind that
transmits other encephalitic ease these
are viruses almost all of which are
flabby viruses but not all of them
you've got Japanese be encephalitis
you've got lacrosse virus you've got
come on Vince help me out here I'm going
to go down a big list equine
encephalitis both Western and Eastern
those are nasty infections and then
you've got the West Nile infection which
is not so nasty depending on how old you
are so it's primarily a parasite of
horses and mosquitoes yeah that's not
true it's a primary a parasite of
insects and humans no that's not true
either it's a parasite of birds it's a
bird parasite just like lacrosse virus
is a bird parasite and st. Louis
encephalitis is another one of those
flabby group viruses and that too is a
parasite of birds and mosquitoes so you
did you know that mosquitoes fed on
birds yeah probably hadn't thought about
it right why would you think about it
until just now so these it will bite
Birds if birds are present but if birds
are not present and these other two
groups of animals will serve as blood
donors in a pinch now if we look back in
history and look at the discovery line
for the introduction of this virus into
the new world we can begin with 1937
when it was first discovered by some
british and scottish investigators
working in east africa and in Uganda
they were working in the West Nile
district looking for the causative
agents of sleeping sickness now you all
know what sleeping sickness is it's like
maybe a half hour from now in this
classroom but we're going to do our best
not to give it to you so it would
happens all the time in medical school I
taught 38 years in our medical school
and I can always depend on some students
demonstrating sleeping sickness in the
audience because they were hiding behind
the new york times but you can see the
times going all
that's how you know so but they made a
mistake this woman was not suffering
from sleeping sickness she was suffering
from something else how did they know
because she didn't go into a coma she
just got sicker she didn't go into a
coma which you would do in sleeping
sickness right it's ok you can stole you
on it's fine just the suggestion of
sleeping sickness makes people what they
found out it was something brand-new
that they had never seen before so they
took some blood back to their
laboratories and they started to
experiment with it to find out what it
might be this was in the golden age of
discovery of viruses you know we knew
about parasites that you could see with
your naked eye back in the seventeen
hundreds of course tapeworms and then in
the 1800's we learn more about microbes
that you couldn't see but you could
still grow them those are the bacteria
and now we're into stuff that you
couldn't see and you couldn't grow and
they ended up being called filterable
agents right you had a sort of an
introductory lecture on this one I'm
sure so if it passed all the tests and
it still infected you it had to be
something that you couldn't even see
with a regular microscope it took an
electron microscope to see these
particles of things and we're still
having our discussions on twit as to
whether these are life forms or whether
there are chemicals that take advantage
of life forms who cares fact did you get
them and you get sick sometimes from
them right so they discovered that this
was one of those agents a filterable
agent and by 1951 the Israeli scientists
now that there was an Israel began to
work on this parasite why do you think
this was a breed of country for gosh
sakes why would they be interested in a
disease that they discovered in Africa I
mean that's you know kind of silly isn't
it except that because they were living
in the Middle East and the birds were
flying out of Africa to their nesting
grounds in Asia they would stop off in
Israel have a bite with a few geese past
the time of day teach them a few
languages perhaps and share their
diseases with the local mosquitoes and
say you know love to stay but we're a
life nesting pair of storks and we've
got a
they are eggs so be good see when we
come back the meantime of course and the
mosquitoes would bite regular geese and
sometimes the mosquitoes would bite
people like soldiers living in the
middle of the Negev desert on training
missions that were a sloppy with their
water attracting this particular general
of mosquitoes the Killa seems
particularly culex molesta sand that's
that case and they would get infected
not a good thing because they had other
things to take care of besides just
doing exercises in the middle of the
negative that's remaining it's true and
even today is sad to say but it's still
true the biggest outbreak of this
infection that became known as the West
Nile virus occurred in south africa in
1973 it was huge it infected 3,000
people it doesn't sound like a lot right
I mean 3,000 it's a lot but it's not a
lot but if I tell you that for every
infection that could becomes a clinical
case there are about 200 people that got
infected but didn't exhibit the disease
itself clinicians refer to it as an in
apparent infection that's an incredible
number of people then right at six
that's 3,000 times 200 that's 60,000
right that right 600,000 exactly okay I
have a fax checker in the back so
600,000 people during this summer of
heat wave after heat wave followed by an
enormous downpour resulted in the
world's largest outbreak but ha doesn't
hold a candle to some of the ones that
we've had lately so we've got the
world's record on this one in 1999 then
the next time anyone cared about this
thing was the summer that it was
introduced into the United States and so
we'll spend some time talking about how
that might have occurred but you don't
know for sure how it occurred we just
know this that if you look back
throughout a hundred years of us weather
history a hundred years that's all we've
got because before that the instruments
were not reliable this infection
occurred during the hottest driest
summer on record for a hundred years I
think that's climate change and probably
not but it's an abnormal weather pattern
that's for sure so from about the first
of May until august 3rd it might have
rained a half an inch of rain the whole
summer anybody was alive in 1999 here
besides just coming here really how old
were you then I won't even ask but if
you were old enough for your parents to
take you to the zoo you might have seen
the visiting lowland gorillas from
Central Africa they had 19 lowland
gorillas at the Bronx Zoo that you could
go see behind an enormously thick piece
of plexiglass it was as long as this
longer than this room and you could
press your nose up against it and they
could come over and press their nose up
against it which they did a lot of
because they were on tour they were
actually on vacation and they were
waiting that night to go to the latest
Broadway shower I'm sure but in the
meantime than we think come on over here
look at these strange bipeds I don't
have any hair look at their funny faces
and they're looking at us like we're
something weird or something I mean
we're just gorillas it attracted three
million people it's a lot for a summer
and it was hot hot hot and dry dry dry
and people were being bitten bit bitten
by mosquitoes mosquitoes mosquitoes
which were breeding in the goose the
Egyptian goose pond which was right next
door to where this exhibit was and if
you want to talk about polluted water I
can show you this is so polluted you
could have walked on it it was ugly
water but the Egyptian geese didn't care
and Killiks pipiens just adored it they
thought it was fantastic so my
hypothesis is some little Israeli kid
came from uncle it's that I just
recently experienced an outbreak of West
Nile virus in the geese yes that
happened and they came here in northern
Queens the visit their relatives and
they said we're going to take you to the
zone and show you the gorillas you can
see 99
Gorillaz they're all there wall okay I
would have said yeah and so they're
waiting on line the old kids ago they
were all got shirt pants on okay they're
just slapping themselves quite crazy for
these mosquitoes that are not ordinarily
day biters but in this case they made an
exception because of the bonanza of
people that just stood there and took it
birds began to die at the zoo crows Blue
Jays Robins outside the zoo the birds
that died inside the sewer special tour
we'll get to that they didn't just come
from any place the ones that died did
not come from Africa only the African
bird survived and you'd think they would
have noticed that but but there were
African birds next to Asian birds next
to South American birds the South
American flamingos died the African
flamingos lived but when they took the
survey said well some of the flamingos
died and some of them lived and that
doesn't make any sense because we think
this is a new virus we don't think this
is an old virus why Wow all of our birds
are adapted to this virus the one they
thought it was st. Louis encephalitis
which it didn't turn out to be all the
crows and all the Blue Jays and all
Robins would have survived that
infection no problem people still got
sick from it but the birds were okay but
for a newly induced agent introduced the
agent like West Nile people died and
birds died immediately they thought
there was two separate things so you
know you could become house for a moment
right house would have gotten it like
that you would have I know he would've
but he wasn't around them he was just a
hut at that point yeah so from 1999 to
2010 that's only 11 years 11 years come
on you guys are going to run for that
long right now I can see it where were
you 11 years ago it's not a good
question to ask so but you know where
you've been and if you come from all
over the country doesn't matter
rare as long as it's within the
contiguous United States you have heard
of this infection because there has been
an infection in your state but it will
start right here I mean not far from
here northern Queens South Bronx okay
now the other thing about this infection
is that it affects older people rather
than younger people adversely so if
you're a little kid standing on line
waiting to see the gorillas and you've
got a raging West Nile infection going
on in your brain the reason why you
don't suffer so much from it all you
might have a fever who would know what
little kid would say you know I don't
feel so great I don't think I want to go
through the girls come on just got into
your own you're gonna get free candy get
some soda you know they'll take you out
they'll keep you up late because they
want to show you off to all the
relatives and it was hot hot hot hot
right and here at the gorilla exhibit
the head sprayers that would keep you
nice and cool nice and moist for the
mosquitoes to come along and take a bite
so these little kids wouldn't have
suffered much but the adults if we had
it well there's there's a mortality
associated with adult infections for
this and the reason for that is that
your when your brain swells up and
you're old you have these sawtooth
joints in your skull and they just don't
want to move but it was a kid you've
still got lucky you're at that age right
now a little bit older and you won't be
there but right now your brain has some
wiggle room still there's the softness
associated with those such as joints as
a little kid or newborn it's got a big
hole in their head that the blown hasn't
even closed up yet why because otherwise
it can't get out of the birth canal so
all of this relates to the mortality of
this infection lolo age groups here high
mortality and morbidity there even
though everybody's being bitten so you
don't know when the mortality rate is
here's the normal cycle if you're a crow
you're toast that's the end of it a
hundred
and that's an incredible percentage
right Vince what is another virus that
has a very high mortality rate Vince
knows the answer to that so I'm not
going to give him any points for knowing
but who knows if you had a choice of any
viral infection which one would you
choose the least thirty percent HIV
without therapy it's one hundred percent
that's that's a good one some people who
have it got the syndrome and then
recovered so say say how many percentage
of HIV come on there's another virus who
said rabies that's eight well it's
probably a hundred percent without
radical therapy and the way they did
this one as they puts his guy into a
hypothermic condition for about a month
until your immune system could catch up
to the virus and kill it and then they
restored his body temperature and he
lived but he was brain-damaged and it
wasn't wasn't nice so Louie pastor
became famous for making a vaccine
against it so that we wouldn't have to
suffer from that right horses forty
percent and only three to five percent
for humans okay you know what a group of
crows is called someone actually wrote a
very nice melodrama about where they're
using the term a murder of crows because
it's part of naming groups of things
right an exaltation of nightingales for
instance is the one everybody seems to
want to remember but if you call this
group a group of a group of crows is
called a murder of crows how ironic it
is that now that we've introduced the
West Nile virus to this country the
crows are being murdered so there is no
more murder of crows because we've made
love you know thank you yeah so
mosquitoes the real villain of this
episode because without mosquitoes you
won't have transmission to people at
least of West Nile I bestest want to
tell you something else I said I never
go backwards buddy had to go back for
this one if even one of these crows gets
infected from a mosquito bite in three
days they'll be dead but on day two when
all of these crows seek out a tree and
rook in the tree overnight and you've
have you experienced this at home and
the people hate crows at night because
they all right they come into the tree
just like watching it off for Hitchcock
movie right and then of course the next
morning and they'll have to wake up and
go somewhere else so they wake you up in
the morning to early and they don't let
you go to sleep when you want to when
they're in the trees and they're
breathing out in a steady rate all that
co2 is traveling down the branches of
the tree down the trunk into the grass
and it's waking up there vector that's
like hearing and smelling bacon in the
morning bless your Orthodox so these
crows are sitting ducks for for this
mosquito species which just sits in the
grass and waits and that isn't going to
happen until around ten o'clock at night
and that's why I told you if you could
get inside it around nine o'clock at
night and still take your mint julep
inside you'd be fine but in that year
people were so hot and so exhausted by
just sitting around during the daytime
that there were lots of lawn parties
that went on at night and Eric lots of
them especially in northern Queens where
you have inground swimming pools cool
half of the people left it was so hot
they went on vacation and went somewhere
else and to save money because coned was
so draconian in their building that they
actually up the rates and you know what
a great excuse for that they said
rubbing the rates for electricity
to save an electricity you think you're
going to stop using the air conditioner
because it's 120 degrees out that's
eighty percent humidity know you'll just
end up paying a lot more money right so
Khan had raked it in that summer boy did
they rake it in but not from half of the
people living in northern Queens because
they turned off the pumps to their
swimming pools shut down their houses
and when I don't know to Ireland which
would have been a great place to go or
up to Canada someplace or maybe two I
don't know Jackson Hole some little dump
out west who knows so the point is that
these pools became brie breeding sites
for mosquitoes no more chlorine no more
circulation leaves were dropping in
because they were rotting off the trees
because there was no water they were for
the fall came a lot earlier than usual
the nutrients cycle started the water
was acceptable and now imagine sitting
at in August at ten eleven twelve
o'clock two o'clock in the morning it
was Friday night Saturday morning and
people are just getting bitten like you
wouldn't believe amazing so that's
possibly the explanation for why it got
established we had some mosquito jokes
all spoiled by the fact that you could
have access to these files before I
lectured I should have left them out and
just shown you them but Gary Larson has
had a wonderful field day with mosquito
jokes but mosquitoes are not a joke if
you could make them go away the world
would probably be a better thing but a
lot of other animals would suffer
greatly from not having a food source of
mosquito larvae or mosquito adults but
our lives would be certainly much easier
this is the culprit over emphasizing it
because because of the epidemiology of
this thing Killiks pipiens is a night
feeder all right so one of the Gary
Larson cartoon shows is gigantic
mosquito that's probably not that big
but they feel that big and if you're
from New Jersey they are that big it's
our national bird in fact
if we want to know where the virus came
from well then that's pure virology
that's that's it's a living laboratory
here's how you find out you get a viral
particle and you start to sequence it
and the next thing you know you can
match it up with something that already
exists and you say it's that one but it
wasn't actually quite that easy because
we only had seven deaths none of the
birds were looked at right away because
they all thought it was something else
they were sent out to the vet lab in
Iowa the vet lab in Iowa never talks to
the CDC in Colorado which is where the
vector biologists were and so as the cut
as the group in Iowa inoculated the dead
bird tissues and the extracts into other
living birds they of course got them to
die and then they would extract their
blood and tissues and prepare them for
virology and they all came down with
exactly the same shaped viral particle
it's about 40 nanometers look just like
a flabby virus Wow so they called up the
CDC in Colorado and said could you
please send us all of your Ana Sarah for
Flavia viruses because we know that
there was a weak cross reaction with st.
Louis encephalitis virus which is a
flabby but it was weak we think that we
isolated the agent and if we could have
all of the ANA Sarah i bet you we could
identify which lobby virus this was
because they didn't have any sequencing
capacity too bad so the answer came back
from CDC actually we'd like your virus
send it to us and we'll do the
sequencing number but we week about that
that woman okay so they were coerced
into doing this right so they sent them
the virus and Duane gubler was the chief
virologist who was an expert on dengue
fever Oh another flavivirus and they
began sequencing this but in the
meantime of course from some of the
brain tissues of three of the dead
people from northern Queens
untitled together one actually was from
Toronto stopped in New York probably
went to the zoo saw the gorillas got
back on an airplane went to Toronto and
died how unusual is that very but luck
of the draw so this tissue then was
deposited the brain tissue was deposited
in the state of New York's department of
pathology and then in California a
virologist by the name of Ian Lipkin who
you might recognize because he's here
now requested some of those samples he
said maybe I can get some sequence out
of the brain tissue of what's causing
this disease so how would you even start
doing that you take a nun specific
primer thinking it's a virus of some
sort and hope for the best well guess
what in two days of intensive work they
got a partial sequence and they put it
up on promed let's program for
monitoring emerging diseases it's
Stephen Morse established another guy
from Columbia and lo and behold Vincent
duel him in the Pasteur Institute in
Paris said I know what it is this is a
partial sequence of the West Nile virus
oh it's the West Nile virus oh and the
next day of course they had almost
completed the full sequence when they
sent that full sequence to Vincent he
said I know where this comes from comes
from Israel how the hell you know that
how would you know that oh because
somebody also sent us some samples of
geese tissue to Paris to find out which
strain of virus had was the outbreak of
that year 1999 and bingo these two
viruses were different by one base pair
a single base pair do you think that was
a sequencing error I do
because the next closest virus was ten
percent different in terms of its number
of base pairs you don't make a ten
percent sequencing era get to make a 0
point 0 0 0 1 percent error though so it
had to come from was probably from the
same outbreak so how could that virus
from Israel get to New York do you know
any people take ll Airlines over the
summer time per week it's 300,000 people
300,000 people travel back and forth
between Israel and the United States
that's a lot of people so one of those
people had to be a little kid by rimac
came to visit went to the zoo inoculated
the mosquitoes at the zoo and the
mosquitoes in northern Queens and the
next thing you know we had an outbreak
now I didn't I made that up by the way I
just made that up so you don't have to
write it down but when i had the lunch
with vincent doable and white plains
when the government-sponsored of West
Nile virus symposium the following
spring into the year 2000 i said next to
vincent because he thought I spoke
French cuz I have a French name no I had
those that was not French and he knew
that right away so he was very kind and
he says I like your story he says that's
what I think happened to everybody else
was saying birds blew across the
Atlantic off their flyways or they had
stowaway mosquitoes and airplanes which
is possible possible but in two
different places come on the airport
isn't that close to those two places so
it really doesn't drive with the facts
and there are no facts to tell us
exactly what happened but these are this
is the best hypothesis that we can tell
you about and here's Ian and here's
Tracy McNamara she was the zoo
pathologist that said this has got to be
the same virus even though there are two
groups infected birds and people I think
this is the same virus and
course they laughed at her because the
test at the CDC in Atlanta had showed a
week cross reaction with st. Louis
encephalitis which never kills birds
just makes people sick so it can't be
two things no it can't be the same thing
it has to be two things so she was
actually vindicated in the long run she
was so let's see what this thing looked
like then just take a look at these maps
just briefly and here's the very first
outbreak map this was 1999 62 total
cases clinical cases x 200 right that's
how many total infections the next year
21 cases less why I know why I can look
to raise my hand because it was the
wettest coolest summer on record for a
hundred years the year before that it
was the hottest driest the very next
year was the coolest wettest climate
change no you still can't do it like
that climate change is long term but
these are weird perturbations in weather
and they affect the outcome of lots of
things including diseases the next year
at 66 cases but look at now we've got
some virus infections in the south how
did it get down there it's part of the
Flyway it's also part of the highway how
many people go down south in the winter
to get away from the winter lots of
people right so you could imagine
mosquitoes wintering over in your car
trunk taking them down to Florida and
these areas and then opening your
drunken outcomes the mosquitos and then
you can introduce them this way but i'll
show you another way to 2002 we had a
heat wave that you wouldn't believe but
not in not in the east so much as in the
Midwest and 4,000 cases that's more than
South Africa you multiply that times 200
you've got 800 thousand cases or eight
thousand eight hundred thousand
infections rather the next year all even
better yet you know we're good at this
we're good at this United States is very
good at
catching West Nile virus 6,800 cases and
with lots of deaths another year just an
angle year later and only Washington in
West Virginia and some of the New
England states didn't report infections
are cases that year but look as you move
this map again and again eventually all
of the states come in to register there
isn't a single state now that hasn't
recorded some cases of West Nile
infection throughout the entire country
this is the latest one that we had to
add just yesterday because it wasn't
available i guess i looked for it i
didn't find it until yesterday at least
so you got two different groups of
things here the light green is the
presence of the West Nile virus in
wildlife and mosquitoes and the other
part the darker groups the darker green
is the number of people and the places
where they were infected and we had
about I think it was about 350 cases all
together a West Nile but in every single
instance it happened where it was dry
dry hot hot you know I told you that
mosquitoes are aquatic breeders right so
if it's hot and dry where the hell is
the water coming from it's coming from
the golf course faucets it's coming from
the graveyards where you would put a
little water in the container and the
flowers for your loved ones to as a
memorial it's coming from the little
kids swimming pool it didn't quite get
emptied the coming from the old tire
that didn't quite get emptied it's
coming from the birdbath that's kept on
because you feel sorry for the birds
because they don't have a place to go
that's true it's true come on you know
this is true so now a summary of this
information quite remarkable actually
we've in 11 years we've got a total of
thirty thousand seven hundred and two
cases we've had a thousand two hundred
and three deaths from a four percent
mortality rate in the beginning it was
over ten percent and it reduced over the
third year the mortality rate went from
about eight percent it
in half to four percent and it stayed
there ever since but there's one place
where it's still pretty high I'll give
you one guess as to which state has the
highest mortality rate and it hasn't
changed throughout the entire epidemic
Calif not California Texas Texas and
I'll try to say something about that
we've had a total of six million
infections with West Nile is this enough
for her immunity this is the country now
totally protected because there's
lifelong immunity here or at least long
immunity you can't read that joke but it
shows a mosquito a pair of mosquitoes
and they're flying over what looks like
mosquito bumps and they're saying this
place is all sucked out let's go
somewhere else have enough people become
infected to protect all the others that
have not become infected yet we don't
know guess what what day is today may
second time will tell all you have to do
is wait and if it's a drought a year in
some places where big epidemics have
already happened and nothing happens and
those same people are still there it's
probable that herd immunity is kicked in
and it's starting to protect this
country against big outbreaks but it
took us a long time this joke appeared
pretty early on and the outbreaks you
going you know I wouldn't kill you to
grab guys side and get some exercise
will when the mortality was ten percent
it just might have so what have we
learned from all of this why the rapid
spread West no it wasn't because the
wind was blowing the mosquitoes from
east to west because it blows in the
opposite direction so if your mosquito
and you go up into the air column you
find yourself out over the Atlantic
Ocean birds migrate north and south so
that's probably not going to be it
either you're not going to take
infections from here and go all the way
over here by bird migrations and besides
birds are getting sick and they're dying
so it's kind of hard to fly when you're
sick there is one way though that I can
think of it's complicated but it
probably is going to turn out to be the
case because somebody actually
introduced a genetic marked mosquito
here and traced it all the way across
the country and it only took about two
years not bad so how does that work
alright ecologically maybe here i have a
course in ecology do they give courses
here in downtown campus in ecology
directly like it says ecology and not
city urban life or you know something
spun off in another direction this is
real ecology all right did you take the
course excellent do you know what this
word means I didn't think so not too
many not too many do but if you're our
age like the three of us these are this
is an acapella singing group the
technical heads
the Eco tongues it's a little bit of
great sound singing in the boys room but
it turns out that what Eco tones are our
borders between separate ecosystems can
you think of an example of that and I
can you build a highway through a forest
lots of them right eat and you had an
intact ecosystem the forest and you cut
it in half with this road and the next
thing you know you've got unusual things
growing alongside the road and unusual
animals that only occupy that zone
that's bizarre but that's the way it is
that's called the edge effect you might
have known the ecotone as the edge
effect yes okay we had a connection here
so we've we've built up these road
systems with federal dollars
particularly after the Second World War
so we've got all these east-west roads
and we've got all these north-south
roads and those are the eco tons that I
think are transmitting this infection
from one place to the next because crows
are the main host and crows eat
alongside the road and what are they
eating they're eating bugs that bounce
off your windshield mainly that's what
they're reading or you know you see the
meeting on a carcass and you'll say
they're carrion eaters well they are
they're not you know what they're doing
they're picking the contents out of the
stomach's of the animals that died it
sounds pretty disgusting but that's the
way the crow is all right so that's
mainly what they eat but if they're in a
pinch they'll eat the carcass too but
mostly they don't have to because they
have a rich supply of insects that are
being supplied to them daily by all this
interstate transportation so here's some
of the crows for you to contemplate
that's why I put them in okay but did
you know what that group was who knows
what this group is counting crows
excellent XH and this one of course it's
self labeled and of course this guy used
to work for us that's Michael crow the
season on the president of Arizona State
University so some of us do pretty good
afterwards
right because we came from a good place
and then it'll happen to you too I'm
sure so we have other birds that get
infected besides crows we got blue jays
we got Robins I love this little kid
like you know isn't he just adorable
couldn't you just like pinch him in the
cheeks when you just take him to the zoo
to see the gorillas I would this one I'm
not sure about he's a little I don't
know so what triggers the infection in
people then if this is this mosquito
likes Birds why does it go to people
it's a very good question so hot hot hot
dry dry dry if it's that for more than
two weeks and the temperature goes above
90 degrees you can depend on a human
case but not before that so let's say
it's hot a hot and it's dry dry and
you're a bird you know you gotta be no
you can stand about a week of this your
food supply starts to shrink up your
water supply starts to disappear it's a
no-brainer just going to fly somewhere
else you can fly yes you can fly
frequent flyer my house now you can just
fly just get up and fly so go away go
where the water is go where the insects
are go where the flowers are that's what
you eat so that's what the birds do this
really pisses off the Killiks pipiens
population however because that's their
food supply what are you going to do now
I don't know what do you guys do when
you get low on money so you look at the
drought drought watch which is a usgs
website and you match up the drought
sites with the case outbreaks and you've
got it that's easy and it works here's
our hypothesis you can read all this
stuff it's pretty simple stuff actually
it just means that when it's cool and
and wet the birds stick around the
mosquitoes have all the food they want
and when it's hot and dry them Birds go
away leaving us and then they
you really want to eat a human it's not
safe we'll do it anyway so here's the
actual data for this and I had one of
our students at the school of public
health collect here are the cases in
blue and here's the temperature here for
a drought that occurred in the Midwest
and there was a one-to-one correlation
between 90 degree temperature first day
and above lucious three to five days
later a human case of West Nile why
would the temperature matter the ambient
temperature mosquitoes live at the
ambient temperature they're infected
with viruses for every 10 degrees of
increase of temperature what's the
biochemical rate increase anybody souls
giving me the peace sign he usually
gives me the peace sign well it's almost
a piece on its a half of a peace sign no
but in this case it was a thank you that
was a dick cavett referenced by the way
so he says it's such a friendly sunny
city when he first came here from the
Midwest he says everybody was giving me
the peace sign with hailing cab he would
give you the peace sign it was he says
what was it was a half of the peace sign
actually so he said for so for every 10
degrees of bile of temperature the
reaction time doubles and that's true
for manufacturing mosquito viruses as
much as it is for manufacturing
mosquitoes so the load of virus that it
can inject India goes way up from 80 to
90 degrees and apparently that matters
okay now no one's ever done the
experiments to actually prove that in
humans they did in Israel in birds and
birds need far less why is that think of
a good reason for them what's the body
temperature of humans most of us not him
but most of us it's 98.6 what's the body
temperature of birds higher so as soon
as that virus enters the bird what its
jack'd its rate up a little bit
sometimes pretty high so here's the way
the mosquitoes look at all this this is
the view of the world through the eye of
the mosquito okay
here's a mosquito looking at crows
thinking steak that's what we would
think if we saw the chrome right but
you've seen this joke that's no fair I
don't get a chance to surprise you with
this because here's what they see when
there's no more birds around and they
have to fight a pair a person but you've
all recognize this person right because
he says whoa weird all the birds go I
hell reproduction Trump's little plan
words good taste every time so you got
to reproduce no matter what is it that
offense of a joke I'm sorry she's a
relative of done that's okay so you know
of course which when I made this joke up
just to let you know that mosquitoes
won't bite people unless there's nothing
left that's that that's the point here
so you have to say what would drive away
burns besides hunters or poison they
they did some poisoning of birds in
Central Park in 1999 which was a red
herring it threw off everybody because
they were trying to eliminate a
particular toxin that exterminators were
using to kill cockroaches and it looked
like little rice grains they said would
put animals will eat this and think it's
rice and they'll die hey yeah I know and
in fact that's exactly what happened and
so the state legislature was meeting to
actually ban it at the request of the
Audubon Society when they decided to do
a little demonstration as to how serious
they were about keeping this poison so
in five separate city parks on one day
hundreds and thousands of birds were
dead eating these little pellets and so
then they thought no maybe they're dying
from that but of course that wasn't the
case but it threw them off a little bit
in 1999 they never caught those people
by the way so what's the difference
between Donald Trump and hot dog
Oh would you saw that joke come on
you're just being polite my wife is
right about this then she said no one
laughs at your jokes they're just being
polite she's probably right so what
about the change of atap mortality rates
here's it went up to as high as fifteen
percent if you throughout Texas it was
around seven percent so we think the
difference is between Texas and
California it's not the same as hot dogs
and Donald Trump there's something in
common between Texas and in California
they both accept lots of migrant workers
in the summertime for farming so that's
the case they both the firm the front
workers come from the same places
depending on what the workload is and
what the kind of crop is and so they
they go to both places then they both
hot hot hot dry dry dry hot hot hot
welcome back hot hot hot dry dry dry in
texas and in california and so in
California Texas they start to get sick
ah I see what you're going to say which
state has the best health care system
California or Texas I'd rather be sick
in California that's what this means if
you're sick in California they're going
to rush you to a hospital and they will
treat you in Texas they will try to take
you back home so you can get excellent
care in your own little village south of
Nogales which isn't even in Texas by the
way it's near Arizona so Texas is
draconian in their treatment of migrant
workers in California is less draconian
they don't pay them enough of course in
either case but at least in California
they get better health care but
something happened right over here to
the virus so this is really hard to read
so I guess I'll have to read this one
for you I think I brought my glasses no
I didn't so the first article I wouldn't
show you no matter what because it costs
45 dollars to buy and I said thank you
but no thank you 45 dollars for a single
article come on I have published
textbooks that don't cost that much
but it may not be worth that much either
that's another way to look at it but but
this one here says multiple pathways to
the attenuation of West Nile virus in
Southeast Texas thank God had happened
there right in 2003 and so what they did
was they analyzed all of these different
strains of the West Nile virus from all
over the state and they found three
separate groups of mutations in separate
places on the viral genome and none of
them had anything to do with what they
thought the virulence factors were for
the virus but in every case the variants
of the virus one-tenth so obviously it
must have something to do with the
virulence but they don't know what it is
three separate point mutations that
resulted in a change of death rate in
people not in Crows so we're nearing the
end here right I've got how much more
time ah time for questions so we have
lots of unanswered questions you can ask
these questions if you want but we don't
have any answers we have a lot of
outbreak data not just in this country
but is all over the Mediterranean Basin
because that's where the birds come up
out of Africa to go to to lay their eggs
raise their young come back a lot of
outbreaks in Russia lots in spain italy
in the kumar's region of france so from
my perspective I have two big worries
right I love being outdoors i love
wandering nature i'm a high-risk person
here for severe effects of this virus so
you have to weigh the odds i don't like
hot hot dry dry anyway so that's okay
but if you live in scottsdale what is
everybody anybody ever been to
scottsdale arizona i'll give you the
give you the mantra for Scottsdale
Arizona it's hot hot hot dry dry dry
rich rich rich it's where the Frank
Lloyd Wright school of architecture is
for the summer taliesin west and i had a
very nice experience there but it's also
where a lot of retired people go and
it's only got two hundred and seventeen
thousand people almost half of them are
between the ages of 45 and 65 years old
and none of them are from Scottsdale and
what do you think they like to do in
Scottsdale golf what a waste of time ok
Golf is a great sport but look at where
they are there in the middle of a
goddamn desert what the hell are you
doing playing golf in the middle of a
desert and they want it to look like
it's not in the middle of a desert so
they water the heck out of it they have
greens and fairways and lots of dripping
water lots of discarded water well
they're their own worst enemies then
because I can predict with surety that
eventually on West Nile virus outbreak
will occur there in fact I'm predicting
the past because it happened last year
the other thing I worry about a lot is
exotic western birds have you visited
the Everglades yeah you're seeing
spoonbills and ibises and storks and
stuff is that cool it's great we've got
a country that has that stuff in it
right we didn't make ladies hats out of
all of it we tried but then they
switched fashions or something else and
so we stopped that so all these exotic
birds are down there and we know that
they're highly susceptible to this
infection I had the privilege last week
and a half ago to visit Wisconsin on
earth day right or I guess it was april
twentieth and so April 21st I had
nothing to do because that my ticket was
from april to a second so i took a trip
out into the countryside and i stumbled
on the International crane recovery
center there are 15 species of cranes
the sandhill crane is the native to this
area but there are 14 other species
Siberian cranes and waddle cranes and
royal crown cranes and I saw every one
of them at this center and in fact I was
the only I was the only other person
there there was three inches of snow of
the ground to it wasn't such a great day
for visiting except that it was the sun
was out except the guy that sat down
next to me and he's crumpled old hat
with a camera he turned out to be the
guy who established it some had a nice
talk with him his name was George
Archibald and in the course of the
conversation she says and what do you do
and I said you should ask me what I did
rather than what i do now I'm retired
but what i did was i worked on
infectious diseases and I said you know
I'm really worried now that I know that
the center is here I'm worried about
your cranes because West Nile virus is a
baddie and the grill crowned crane will
not die that's an African bird in fact I
actually saw that bird once in Kenya so
I know where it comes from but the
sandhill cranes are certainly
susceptible to this and so were a lot of
the other species Siberian cranes is
only about he said they're about 50 left
and he was involved in the recovery of
the whooping crane you hate big oil
right everybody here hates big oil right
except the American emco the American
oil company right momoko amo CEO they
were the ones that funded the research
that got the crane back on its feet it
was at one point 11 individuals another
over 500 that's amazing isn't it we
think the genetics of that is when the
MHC complex comes down to 11 individuals
I think they're all inbred and now I
asked him it has anybody been doing the
genetics of this because they're now
radiating back out again what's the
mutation rate in in whooping cranes
because they better mutate fast enough
to become resistant to them well that's
not going to happen either it area
that's my biggest worry is the exotic
bird recovery species in this country we
have a condor Recovery Act also going on
now further west and I actually got a
call from them a long time ago asking
what the chances were that
birds would get nailed by this infection
where are they located in the middle of
the hottest driest area that you can
imagine Lake Powell so that's that's got
potential at least but it's in the
middle of nowhere so there are no people
so there are no mosquitoes so therefore
they're pretty safe I think so what's
next but don't know so that's basically
my presentation so now where you can
open it up to discussion and you can
find out just how much biology I don't
know you already know more than I do I
can tell you this right now if you want
to feel really good about yourselves for
having gone through this course you know
much more virology than I do right
because I tried to answer your exam and
I knew about the seven different
replication ways of a viral genome but
there was a lot of other stuff that I
just didn't know so I'm throwing myself
at your feet and begging for mercy and
but please ask questions yes say it
again that's a great question you sure
that's the first thing right now what
was has there been a vaccine developed
against the virus well it depends on who
you ask but I know who to ask because
Tom mon ass is a friend of mine Tom
low-mass used to be at Harvard he's a
virologist he studies dengi he got
involved in a madhab mu vax i think is
the company's name as mu vax but making
vaccines against exotic infections and
he decided to do one against the West
Nile virus but it actually wasn't for
people was for horses hey horses well
has anybody ever been doing an
equestrian event they're wonderful
aren't they they're jumpers and there
you know and everything is beautiful but
have you ever been to a horse race never
been tools race I can take you to know
who controls the racing industry I can
tell you who that is too so a vaccine
for horses because if you don't have
vaccines for horses Europe will not
bring our horses here they keep their
horses
wave from the outbreaks in southern
Europe but they could always come here
depending because it never mattered
right a little bit for eastern equine
encephalitis that's not a good disease
for them to get nor is western but they
could come at a time when those diseases
we're not in transmission cycle but West
Nile scared the heck out of them so
they've been working on a vaccine forget
the people it's about the horses it's
about the money follow the money and
that's I'm sorry to say this but that's
exactly the development of that vaccine
is for horses not for people and it
hasn't worked out very well they tried
to piggyback that onto an attenuated
yellow fever virus because that's the
best vaccine in the world where none for
viruses it was one of the first it's an
attenuated viral vaccine they just
passage it through animals until it
doesn't kill them anymore and then you
use that they don't know why but it did
so if you take this and you insert the
genome for the capsid for West Nile that
should offer some protection against
what's now too but they're still playing
with it see I don't know anything about
biology I know that much that's not a
lot though yes
sure yeah that's a great question too
because how would you know if you had it
and how how could you make a decision in
a clinical situation which has nothing
to do with doing a test so they call
that a syndrome so there's a West Nile
syndrome now that they can actually
teach physicians to recognize mental
confusion muscle weakness fever three
things that's it if someone comes into
the hospital nowadays with those three
signs and symptoms that's West Nile
until proven otherwise and they didn't
get it wrong so what would you do for it
then for kids you won't even know they
had it because they don't get that sick
but for an adult of my age should give
me steroids if you give me steroids
what's that going to do it's going to
keep the inflammation of my brain down
it won't keep the infection from going
on it won't keep my brain cells from
being killed you probably never tell the
difference before and after anyway so
that's fine but we don't use that much
of our brain so I can afford a little
bit to the west nile virus but but the
swelling that occurs during the
encephalitis is what kills you and
you're going to a call when you die
that's what does it so if you get the
diagnosis early enough and you start
supportive therapy as it's called not
antivirals not any of that fancy stuff
that you can think about using just
support therapy + steroids you save
lives so part of this reduction in
mortality was a quick response of
clinicians alerted by Public Health
notification that it's been hot and dry
for the last week be on the lookout for
the first case of West Nile an early
warning system that's probably all we
need except in Texas need a new governor
in Texas i think yes
yeah there are plenty of them you could
do that yeah that would be an easy one
you can even culture it if you wanted
but most of them are done presumptively
now they do that a lot in Africa for
malaria when a patient comes in and
they've got a big spleen because you can
feel it and most of them you can feel it
not on me they would never find it but
in some people they could find the
spleen and it's way below the cost of
margin and it's big they call it big
spleen disease as long as your livers
and swollen it has to be just spleen
because otherwise this could be another
disease they can do surveys for malaria
just by feeling for the spleens and
little kids and if they find it they do
mass treatment of the whole village and
it works you know can keep it down this
way all right until resistance occurs
and that's of course happening all over
the place now so we're a little bit
worried about any overuse of any anti
any things there must be other questions
here's the biggest question that I hoped
you would ask but perhaps I can prod you
into this why should we care about this
anymore this is a non-issue try to get
on the news agencies nobody wants to
hear about this is that break it was now
big deal who cares it's way below the
radar screen it's on the third page of
the news of notes section of the Social
Register I will know by the way Jones
died of West Nile that's them it's like
hearing about Lyme disease everybody's
used to it you get a bitumen you don't
react this is a flavivirus listen to the
other floppy virus is your fever dengue
Japanese be encephalitis this was
introduced into this country at a single
point now we know where it went we know
how it got there we know all those
details so you want to do some research
on this so you called the CDC and you
say I would like the records for the
outbreaks of 2006 2007 I want a GPS
nation for each case i want the time it
occurred because I've got a hypothesis
as to how this might have all gotten
together to form the epidemiologic basis
for the outbreak and they'll say well
you can get all that information from
the state health authorities okay let's
see which state would you pick one of
the most cases fine call up Nebraska oh
I'm sorry we can't give you that
information we have to call the Centers
for Disease Control for that and so you
just start doing this and the reason why
you can't get that information as I
learned at a meeting at the Institute of
Medicine and I oh this was the only
closed-door meeting they had in 20 years
this could be used by bioterrorists to
introduce a vector borne disease and
they know what the pattern is now so
they could try something like this with
a much more virulent organism so you're
worried about bioterrorism just
something to just file that away and oh
my god I never even thought about that
was worried about where my next meal was
going to come from ah it's true though
because the government actually ends up
controlling this information and I tried
really hard through students and through
my own contacts to get that information
so I can work with it and model it and
it's not available to the public or even
to the private it's not available to
investigators and I had a chance to talk
with somebody in the in the homeland
defense department even know what
they're going to call themselves now but
whatever they think they are and they
said you're right this information is
not for general consumption because you
know if your model is right we mean if
my boxes writer how is he going to find
out unless you have the data right so
can you imagine having that data and you
can just do this mental picture take
1999 that's then the map is right there
it's not going to change and there's
this little car sir that you
can move across and it goes from 99 to
2011 and as it goes across the epidemics
occur and at the same time the drought
watch occurs and at the same time bird
deaths occur at the same time mosquito
pool infections occurred run that movie
for me you can run the movie now you can
make it happen in your mind you can
watch it you just press that video it's
got that little triangle and you can
watch it weather comes up no Lulu if I
could have shown you the movie it would
have taken 20 minutes and we could have
been done here all right so write your
Congressman tell them to release the
data so that we can start playing with
it because if you can't do good science
without the data without the input we
can make up any story we want here and
we can tell it to you as if it's a true
story but unless this is based on
reality you have a right to question it
and you have a right to say well that's
a partial truth or that's maybe not even
the fortress so here's the final quote
did you give them this quote Vince trust
science don't trust scientists because
we all have our opinions but science
isn't the pin it's not an opinion it's a
way of gathering information and
manipulating it so thank
you